in this first what i'll call this is my
first real linear algebra video let me
write that down linear algebra video I
want to introduce you to some concepts
that you're going to see over and over
in linear algebra and if they're not
introduced to you properly in the
beginning they can be very confusing but
hopefully over the course of this video
you'll understand that they're pretty
pretty straightforward ideas and if
anything in linear algebra the field or
the gods of linear algebra are kind of
experts in to some degree stating simple
and obvious things in and convoluted in
Byzantine ways but it does that for a
reason it gives it mathematical rigor so
the first thing I want to introduce you
to is kind of the set notation for real
numbers and then multiple dimensions of
real numbers so if you ever see this and
are with kind of an extra backbone like
that or sometimes it's written as just a
a really bold faced RF if it's maybe
typed in a book a really bold faced are
all this means this just means the set
of all real numbers and I haven't done
and I probably should make a few videos
where I classify numbers by reals and
complex and irrational and and and
rational and whatever else but my brain
and there's there's actually very formal
ways of defining the real the set of all
real numbers but the simple thing for me
is all numbers except complex ones so
this is the same thing as everything
everything but complex complex numbers
so pi is a real number e is a real
number square root of two is a real
number three is a real number minus
three is real number minus pi is a real
number but one plus one plus 2i not a
real number not in the set of reals
that's a complex number so everything
but complex so pretty much all regular
numbers that you ever dealt with before
you learned what I was that's the set of
real numbers now the next thing you'll
see in a when you start discussing
linear algebra is someone will write
they won't just write the set of all
real numbers they'll do it though right
are
I'll just write it generally they'll
write our and any like gee what is that
somehow are they somehow taking the
exponent of all of the real numbers and
actually on some level that's that that
is what they're doing but what they're
saying here is you're taking they're
taking the the set of all ordered sets
of real numbers so what do I mean by
that so let me let me do an example
where I don't just have our n so r 2 is
the set of all all is all lists of real
numbers and let me make one of the list
so let's say you know this has one
number and then it has another number so
it's a set of let me write it this way
so i can write instead of notations it's
the set of all we could call these two
poles sometimes it's called a 2-tuple i
want you two to two pole which just
means us just a list of two numbers
that's all it means it just means a list
of two numbers so r 2 is the list of all
ordered two tuples so all ordered lists
of two numbers let me actually write
down the word ordered because that's
important so ordered ordered list of two
tuples so for example this would be well
let me let me write it this way this
would be a different when I say ordered
I'm saying that this is fundamentally
different than that that these aren't
the same 2-tuple each of these is a
2-tuple but r 2 is the set of all two
tuples is a set of all two tuples such
that that lines they're just mean such
that or maybe for which such that each
of each of the each of the numbers each
of the numbers and I'll write it this
way I could just write well I could
write it a couple of ways but I'll write
it and I'll write in the harder to
understand way just so you get used to
it such that X I is a member of the
reals so member of that's what this this
member of that's what this little
character means so that each X I is a
member of the real so what do you mean X
I well X i just means any of these x
is and I'll write for four I is less
than or equal to 2 and greater than or
equal to 1 and I is an integer integer
now I could have I could have written
this a bunch of different ways you might
you know this is almost silly how much
effort I'm taking to write this this way
but I could have written it like this
too I could have written the r2 is equal
to the set of all ordered tuples X 1 X 2
such that I could have just written you
know such that x 1 and x 2 are a member
of the real so I could have written it
that way that would have been an easier
way to write it but either way I think
you get the idea it's all of the
combinations of two things so I said in
the beginning I was like this kind of is
this kind of is where'd operator and why
does it mean what you know why do they
write it as a superscript there and my
gut sense is if you think about it in
this you know you have kind of a an
infinite well look you have an infinite
number of real numbers I mean you you
it's it's I won't go into things like
accountability accountability and things
like that but you have a very large
number of real numbers but let's say
that you only had n real numbers right
let's say that we weren't you know we
weren't dealing with reals that's just
just for sake of argument let's say that
you had like 100 real numbers right so
that means that there would have been a
hundred possibilities there and then
there's another 100 possibilities there
so now you're set of all of the
possibilities of two tuples well you'd
have a hundred times 100 possibilities
so you'd almost have the squared number
of possibilities so however many
possibilities you have for our so you
have that many squared possibilities for
our 2 which doesn't make a lot of sense
because you have an infinite number of
possibilities but you have that many
more possibility you have an infinite
number of possibilities here and an
infinite number of possibilities here so
it's almost a greater infinity of
potential possibilities now what's r 3 r
3 is just the same thing r 3 is our
three is if I or someone wrote are three
that means you're going to have you know
you're going to have three points
or three numbers I want to be careful
not to just say points when we we can
graph these things and for example are
two points and are two can normally be
graphed on on graph paper and kind of a
unjust in Cartesian coordinates points
in our three can be graphed in three
dimensions points in just our or we
could just say r1 you could just graph
those on a number line if I'd to graph
you know I could have a number line like
that and if I had to graph pie you know
that's zero I just say they hate right
there that's pie and I've had two graphy
I'd say hey right there that's e and
I've had to graph wanted say hey there
that's one so you could graph them but I
want to be careful that you don't
necessarily they don't have to graph
them they don't have to correspond to
actual physical points on a graph but
anyway when you talk about our three
you're literally just talking about all
the all the possibilities where you have
an ordered set of three numbers where
all three numbers are a member of the
real numbers that's all you're saying
now I'm going to introduce you to
another definition of a vector of vector
now a vector you've seen before you've
seen it in physics where you said oh
it's something that has a magnitude and
a direction you saw it in calculus when
we and we plotted them and whatever not
but I'm going to be very formal and very
abstract and very broad with a vector
right now because that I guess the
beauty of linear algebra is that it
doesn't just apply to things like
physics and it doesn't just apply well
it applies it does apply a lot to
physics but it doesn't just apply to
that effect in linear algebra you can
apply it to anything it doesn't have to
apply to things that you know just
graphs in three dimensions and we'll
talk more about that in the future but
that's why I'm trying to stay stay
pretty pretty abstract so I'm going to
define a vector in RN a vector to be in
RN actually let me be careful I haven't
even defined what RN is I just defined
r2 and r3 so let me define our n RN r n
is equal to the set of all n-tuples
ordered n tuples so you have x1 x2 all
the way over to xn so you're going to
have n
so if this was 100 you would have a
hundred things here so you have this is
an ordered ordered n-tuple this is an
ordered n-tuple such that each of the
for each X i where X is one of these is
a member of the real so each of these
has to be a real number and then I'll
just say for I is less than or equal to
n less greater than or equal to one so
all that saying is that 4x you know X is
X 1 is a member of the reals x2 is a
member of the rails all the way up to xn
is a member of the reels are n is the
set of all of these possible ordered
ordered n tuples or ordered sets of n
numbers so what is a vector what is a
vector in RN well a vector in RN really
is just a particular instance of one of
these n tuples I'll just call it an
ordered list an ordered list of n real
numbers and real numbers and you can
represent a vector in a bunch of
different ways you could you could
represent it you know you could you
could represent it like this you could
represent it you could you could
represent it like well let me do it a
bunch of different ways you could you
know a two-dimensional vector you could
represent like x1 x2 kind of like a
coordinate you could maybe represent it
with brackets like that these are all
this is just syntax this is just
different ways of representing the same
information the same idea and for most
of what we talked about linear alg we're
going to represent them is essentially
these columns and subtle in the very
near future will represent them as rows
as well but I'm going to define our my
vector and a vector is an RN is an
ordered list of n real numbers and I
define and this is an example so it
would be v1 v2 all the way to VN where
each of these where each of these is a
member of the real numbers so it's a
member of the real numbers
and just to make sure you kind of
understand the notation or or the
terminology each of these is called a
component component component of of our
vector and actually I want to be very
careful here because when we write
vectors you want to make sure you have a
nice bold VI won't make all my v's in
the future that bold but that's how when
you're reading a math book that you they
differentiate between just a vector and
just a regular quantity right these
regular quantities are just written with
a with a non bolded while the vectors
are bolded now I'm going to define two
definitions for 22 operations for
vectors in RN I'm going to define
addition so that so and these are
definitions I could have defined them in
our any arbitrary way but these I think
you'll find to be somewhat natural so
these are definitions definitions these
are just kind of human abstract
constructs that end up becoming very
useful so they said hey let's make some
definitions let's define edition edition
so if I have some vector if I have some
vector let me write it as a lowercase a
but it's a really bolded lowercase a and
then that is equal to a1 a2 that's all
of its components all the way to a n and
I want to add that and then I have
vector B and I'm going to make that a
really bolded be right there is equal to
b1 b2 all the way to be n I'm going to
define addition of these two vectors to
be just the sum of each of their
components a bolded a plus bolded B+
bolded b is equal to a new vector a new
vector is equal to a new vector where
you just add each of their components it
can be a one plus b1 is going to create
this new component eight
+ b2 all the way down to a n plus BN and
of this you found this somewhat
confusing just think I mean it i'm
almost going through pains to write
something very simple and very confusing
terms if I if I have two vectors in R 2
let's say I have the vector 2-1 and I
want to add that to the vector 3 I've to
I literally just add each of the
corresponding components so I had the
first components to each other so 2 plus
3 is equal to 5 minus 1 plus 2 is equal
to 1 that's all my definition of vector
addition is but for my vectors in real
numbers and now the next thing I'm going
to define is the idea of a scalar
multiple so scalar multiple you might
remember from physics class a scalar is
just a regular number or if you're
multiplying something by a scalar you're
just scaling it up maybe I should use
the same word in the definition but I'm
going to define it as let me say C is a
scalar so let's say I some I notice I
didn't bold the C so C times my vector a
times my vector a and here I'm going to
take pains to bold it up times my vector
a is going to be equal to all of my
components of vector a multiplied by
each x c so a1 a2 all the way to AI n
and they're each going to be multiplied
by C so that's all I define but you know
every term is going to be x c and just
to give you an example like that if I
wrote if I wrote minus minus 3 times
some vector I'll just draw the vector
here let me draw a vector in r3 so let's
say it's it's let's say the first term
is I don't buy the second term is minus
2 and then the third term is 0 then this
is just going to be equal to this is
just going to be equal to a new vector
in r3
or you can kind of view it as a three
dimensional vector minus 3 pi minus
three x minus 2 is positive 6 and then
minus 3 times 0 is just 0 so it's that
straightforward you know I they made
this fancy definition but it's fairly
easy to deal with I think and I'll just
make one last definition I'll just make
one last definition and I'll call that
the zero vector the zero vector and
depending on what dimension were and it
just means a vector with all zero so the
zero vector in RN if it's arbitrary is
just of just a vector where everything
is zero and if this is RN you just have
n components and components so those are
all my definitions I think I've given
you kind of enough to think about right
now in this video in the next video I'm
going to show a bunch more of examples
and I'll actually draw representations
of these vectors although you don't have
to and we'll kind of have a little more
visual understanding of what they mean